[Musik]
normal ist
wieso operieren sie so gern sofort sind
gern mit hand ich habe wahnsinnig gern
die who so dick mit der hand ein schönes
machen uns operieren ist das kunstwerk
bald los stephanie von orelli ist
chefärztin der frauenklinik chefärztin
stefanie von l'oréal ist mutter dreier
kinder viel arbeit wenig freizeit ist
dieser strebens wert oder einfach nur
anstrengend
warum ist sie ärztin geworden und
deshalb ist der frauenförderung so
wichtig
davon handelt dieser finden wie man den
alltag von stefanie von aurélie
dokumentieren muss man früh aufstehen
ihr tag fängt um viertel vor sechs an
die familie schläft noch als chefärztin
arbeitet sie zwölf stunden am tag
sie sei eben wie sie sagt und brauche
wenig schlaf sich so für mich darauf vom
tag und zitate ruhig und langsam gott
und nach münchen und sagen dass
eigentlich sie dass die einzige ruhige
minute ihren lappen
im moment glaube ich schon zweimal waren
sie die klasse hält
kurz vor 7 geht sie aus dem haus vor
neun uhr abends ist sie jeweils nicht
zurück
[Musik]
stefanie von orelli ist fachärztin für
gynäkologie und geburtshilfe
sie gehört zu einer neuen generation von
chefärzten die sich nicht als göttinnen
in weiß verstehen steiles hierarchie
gefälle wie in vielen spitälern
anzutreffen ist ihr fremd
eigentlich wollte sie ja schauspielerin
werden hat sich aber dann doch fürs
medizinstudium entschieden
teamchef fest bahnen die arbeiten aber
damals schnell reagieren wenn man das
langsam sie also so viele facetten
ich habe dann sehr von seiner jetzt die
maternité triemli hat eine lange
tradition
heutzutage gibt es spezialsprechstunden
für risikoschwangere und transsexuelle
und nebenan werden teenie mütter betreut
besonderen wert legt man auf die
psychologische unterstützung der
patientinnen die chefin setzt sich für
job sharing und teilzeitstellen ein auf
der frauenklinik arbeiten zwei männer
und 193 frauen der kfd frauen das sagen
mir da überhaupt nicht ich denke nicht
dass ich für mich total fremd nach
artikel tun dass man das auch gilt dass
man fair miteinander um baut das man
auch kritik wäre ich mal das heißt nicht
dass alle immer nicht nur angelehnt sind
aber dass man fair bleibt und nicht
gegen die unter der gürtellinie und
nicht irgendwelche machtpositionen ohne
titelverteidiger sondern dass man
konstruktiv miteinander umgeht was sie
ärgert wenn frauen nicht genug haben
verantwortung zu übernehmen zaudern und
sich als chefin zu bewerben nicht
realisieren dass ein kater posten heißt
auch bestimmen zu können
wenn man sich diese position hat hätte
man macht oder zur größe sachen usa
gelöst werden
macht ja schon ziemlich entspannend wenn
ich weiß ich habe die rolle hatte ich
stelle die verlangte mehr die
gegnerische verteidigung und sprach und
dort setzte
guck mal das ist online stinknormal
leitungen einfach geringen ungleich sind
sowie das ist speziell süßes regen und
noch was die da machen die eigene rente
haben man muss erst rang am anfang als
mann und eingrenzen oder gewährt damit
ich sehr viel verstanden ist die frage
nicht am anfang und zum teil darüber
drin dass ich mir zum teil also kommen
also so einfach nehme möbeln und das ist
glaube ich habe so möglich den ganz gut
muss begleiten oder dass sie über die
zeiträume und als jetzt hatte dass das
google kommt ja
[Musik]
da müssen wir zusehen und buße
die chefärztin hat sich bewusst für 81
prozent 1 unentschieden ein tag ist für
die kinder reserviert
einmal die woche geht sie mit bulligen
der jüngsten auf den markt der mittel
ist der feiertag und der vielfalt massiv
und ja jetzt das schwierige für mich ist
entlasten damit ein tag mit ihrer suche
und jo lang intensiv mit das macht ich
glaube wenn ich denn mit ringbindung
wenig mit drin und dann spüre ich glaube
das ist wichtig die großeltern aus basel
sind auf besuch
manchmal müssen sie notfallmässig zum
hüten einspringen
ansonsten kümmert sich an drei tagen
eine nanny um die kinder ihre eltern
sind mediziner beide internisten
sie führten zusammen mit einem anderen
ärzte paradis erste gemeinschaftspraxis
in basel
[Musik]
besser durchsetzen
ich habe sehr starke generation lisbeth
von orelli vermittelte ihrer tochter
dass frauen dieselben rechte haben wie
männer
auch das recht auf beruf und karriere
sie das gestört dass ihre mutter sports
tätig ist und so viel schafft mit
sportlicher mode rietheim und hurra
batterie und jetzt stehe ich immer
unterwegs und das ist ja gut finde ich
dass ich meine flügel einbringt und ich
muss sagen dir jetzt viele enorm
profitiert wieder als offizieller
erkläre alles erzählen wenn ich mir mal
schwer fällt wenn ich einmal probleme
liegen ja wenn sie ganz anders geschafft
hätte ich mich enorm verstanden
mittlerweile ist auch bände
viertklässler eingetroffen
von orelli ist ein altes patricia
geschlecht das in zürich seit dem 16
jahrhundert zu den einflussreichsten
familien gehörte dieser name so sagt
stefanie von ohren bedeutet ihr nicht
viel
sie habe ja nichts dafür geleistet
nun kommt anna die mittlere tochter nach
hause
sie besucht eine heilpädagogische
tagesschule weil sie probleme mit der
sprachentwicklung hat
[Musik]
ihre tochter hat probleme mit der
sprachbildung zäsur xi ihrem labor ihren
familien dabei die schwierigkeiten
also sucht man sagt immer ihr sehr gut
betreut und begleitet war heute ein
fehler den hof gewandert sind die filme
wie den op-tisch sie werden viel
abgekommen und mit hintermann apps ganz
gut gesagt dass die kritik und einfach
doch glaube und das getrimmt dann ist in
stein wer klickt und mehrere eltern sind
tot und der stein der weis grüne und
kriegt rom monats begleitet und dass ich
mich spielt solange respektiere und es
gibt ganz intensiv icsid damit ihre wohl
nicht so ein schnitt hat die werden sie
einfach das lager clinton
sie hat immer gesagt eigentlich ihrem
ort wie hat sie das gemeint lima ist ein
sehr ungeduldiger mensch muss sehr
frisch sehr gern die heimische mittring
nachgegangen bislang auf derzeit leider
weiß ich was alle sagen das ganze sozial
und kultur lama vor der familie daheim
so ein hässlicher sondern war mensch nie
hätte sie einen mann geheiratet der
nicht mit anpacken würde sagen ein
architekt arbeitet teilzeit und kümmert
sich einen tag pro woche um die kinder
dass seine frau karriere macht ist für
den franzosen kein problem
man sagt immer in frankreich von frauen
die nicht arbeiten sich die arme sie
hätten nicht interessantes wirkungen
ausgehen nicht interessanteres machen
als guter zu sein und in der schweiz
sagt man das gegenteil
und das sind die zwei zwei extreme
ansichten sind in der schweiz ein trauer
die arbeitet seit manta oder sind die
schlechte mutter also sein pensum
zugunsten der kinderbetreuung reduzierte
waren die reaktionen nicht nur positiv
negative reaktionen habe ich schon
gehört dass man erwartet von männer dass
sie 100 prozentig engagiert sind und
wenn man teilzeit arbeitet zeigt man
dass man nicht 100-prozentig magath ist
das aber das ist nie gefallen das ist
dann schaffst sowieso mehr als ergänzung
ja es ist mutig und stark und ich bin
sehr stolz ist ihre frau ehrgeiziger als
sie ja und stört sie das
mord im rapport welche patientinnen
treten heute ein wem geht es nicht gut
wer hat geboren sein problem war geboren
psi betriebsrat klar positiv
denn hans prechter von 27 5 er bmw
bekommt der 25 jährigen patientin mit
der situation
heute wird eine qualitätsprüfung der
klinik stattfinden weil das triemli eine
weiterbildungsstätte ist müssen gewisse
kriterien überprüft werden
[Musik]
die 50-jährige chefärztin ist auch die
party menz leiterin
sie ist mitglied der spitalleitung also
ganz oben angelangt dass ich eigentlich
schaut wo er sich als ehrliches feedback
von vertrauenspersonen und ich weiß dass
du mir etwas würde zeige ich habe
wirklich ganz gut zu mir um mich immer
wo mir das würde zeigen dass das alter
wird mir sagen wenn das top 3 geschafft
zweimal die woche steht operieren auf
dem tagesplan
außer maria sondereffekte oder der
kamera
[Musik]
stefanie von aurélie spezialgebiet sind
operationen von krebspatientinnen sie
musste lernen dass eine krankheit etwas
schicksalhaftes ist und sie keine schuld
daran hat sie eigentlich und dann sind
wir denn das schwere schicksal
konfrontiert sind zahl von
einzellizenzen wir behalten die
umfassend am 11
und ich bewundere die frauen zum teil
rafi lehrer selber als mensch dann wie
frauen zum teil schicksal tragen
pro jahr erkranken in der schweiz
fünfeinhalb tausend frauen und
brustkrebs die heilungschancen sind groß
wenn der tumor früh erkannt wird
darum hat stefanie von orelli mit
anderen frauen eine brust check
entwickelt
britta von castelberg und stefanie von
orelli teilten sich vier jahre lang die
leitung der farm klinik triemli
jobsharing einer spitzenposition das war
ein unikum brüder von castelberg sei
ihre größte förderung gewesen wärt ihr
alter zu unterschied in dem noch
schlimmer je älter man wird immer wieder
den hit wir immer verbundener und der
netze will ich die jungs gemacht
die zahnklinik leitet enorm viel
profitiert
eines so beobachtet bilder von
castelberg habe sich in der medizin in
den letzten jahren radikal verändert
das schöne zeit aber faktisch ist es so
dass ein patient muss ich aber generell
im spital und immer wieder fragen ob das
dann bei ca es ist sehr schwierig meinte
unter denen voraussetze gelegt die
richtige menschlichkeit zu bewahren
dann hat er druckst rose nach der sie
zum feierabend wo die eltern der ethisch
[Gelächter]
der abend ist gerettet
[Musik]
die freundinnen übernehmen spontan
samstagnachmittag bowlingcenter der
zehnte geburtstag von bell
[Musik]
wir mussten ja mitteilen dass der
samstagnachmittag triemlispital vortrag
der chefärztin zum thema brustkrebs
für mich ist es wichtig das ist die
brust behalten kann
den patientinnen helfen als ärztin sei
dies ihre pflicht sagt stefanie von
orelli und darum arbeite sie super die
familie frau holle und die rollen als
als ärztin und ich sind und ich bin ganz
stolz ja sind die mieten sondern
brauchen
[Musik]